okay I'm still preparing a story on the
case involving actor Jesse Smollett it
was initially reported that he was the
victim of a homophobic attack that
involved a rope around his neck and a
chemical thrown at him and attackers
yelling this is Magga country and we now
have more and more reason to believe
that the truth of the incident is that
the entire thing may have been a staged
attack I've been waiting to do a full
story about it because I'm trying to
figure out the full truth of what
exactly took place but what I have for
you today that I do want to talk about
is a really cringe-worthy video a
face-planting video of twenty20
Democratic candidate Kamala Harris being
asked about this and she really doesn't
handle it well it's actually hard for me
to imagine her handling it even worse
previously senator Kamala Harris called
the Smollett incident a modern day
lynching she tweeted shortly after it
took place this was an attempted modern
day lynching no one should have to fear
for their life because of their
sexuality or color of their skin we must
confront this hate perfectly reasonable
thing to say based on what was known at
the time but of course as I mentioned
it's now appearing more and more that
the attack may have been staged so
predictably Kamala Harris was asked
about it asked about her tweet and she
implodes she handles it terribly first
she pretends not to know about the tweet
being referred to okay maybe she forgot
but then as she's asked again about it
she looks around and what it looks like
to me is that she's looking for a
staffer or a handler or an aide to run
interference to tell the reporter she's
not going to answer the question to say
we've got to go sorry submit your
questions in writing which is just the
worst look in this situation when you're
asked a question and you condescendingly
look away for someone to pull the
reporter away then look back and laugh
it just looks really bad but then she
just stutters and stammers and says well
facts are unfolding and it is one of the
worst politician responses I could
imagine in this situation let's take a
look at it
which tweet what we other about saying
that it is a modern day lynching that
sorry dizzy smaller okay so I will say
this about that case I think that the
facts are still unfolding and I'm very
concerned about obviously totally
cringe-worthy and the worst part is the
looking for someone to take the reporter
away or to take her away or to step into
the middle of it why not just say listen
under this administration we've seen a
coalescing and a catalyzing of the worst
extremist hate elements we've seen
racist incidents we've seen anti-semitic
incidents we've seen the embolden of the
white nationalist right the president's
saying he would pay the legal bills of
supporters who punch the opposition
protesters at his events I commented on
this on the basis of what was reported
initially sometimes cases are not what
they seem this may be one of those cases
but for the most part false crime
reporting and staged crimes are
incredibly rare we'll eventually know
the truth if this was a staged attack
the perpetrators need to be punished the
law prescribes punishment for such
perpetrators that's it like I can't
imagine Pat any worse response
particularly when there is such a simple
and coherent response that she could
have given especially because it's not
like Camilla Harris did anything wrong
by sending out that tweet I mean she was
reporting on what we all thought was
true at the time may still have been
true but we just don't know the veracity
of the claims haven't been verified yet
so she could just say no comment for the
time being she wants to wait until she
hears all the facts out that's all you
got to do even no comment would have
been boring but it would have been
better than what she did and it reminds
me of when there are false rape
allegations and reporters go to people
who said rapists should be punished this
is horrible
and of course the answer is false rape
allegations are criminal people who do
them should
be punished they're also extraordinarily
rare if somebody makes a false rape
allegation if somebody staged an
incident like this they should be
punished let's not get distracted from
the reality that most rape allegations
are true and that most crime reports are
not crimes staged by the person claiming
to be a victim of the crime so just a
total misstep and quite frankly sort of
surprising for someone as seasoned and
typically well prepared as Kamala Harris
is what do you think happened here let
me know and if this was a good response
and I'm missing something please let me
know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show
is on twitter at david pakman show one
of the day's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman which is a free service
that I myself use really useful in many
different ways takes just a few seconds
to link your debit card to privacy calm
then you can create virtual credit cards
that are linked directly to your bank
account and you use those virtual credit
card numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a David
Pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy calm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want
then just delete the virtual credit card
you used and never worry about getting
charged for it it protects you from
getting hacked it protects you when
companies are hacked which happens all
the time
it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link